so welcome everyone I just watched the
movie The Ice Cream sellers I hope you
had a chance to watch it uh it's an
absolutely fantastic uh really
eye-opening uh you know really
unflinching view of uh of the Cox's
Bazaar refugees and I'm here today with
Sohail Rahman the filmmaker uh to you
know to have a q a in discussion
um I'll ask him a few questions but
hopefully we can get a lot more
questions from the audience so to
introduce myself I'm Nila Saldana and
I'm the executive director of the Yale
research initiative on Innovation and
scale that's why rise and the faculty
director of white rice is Professor
moshfik Mubarak in the economics
department at wairise we look at you
know advancing the science of scaling
development and policy interventions and
humanitarian issues such as Refugee and
conflict areas is always in important
because unlike in some ways unlike
regular
you know poverty I shouldn't say regular
but really about you know ongoing and
chronic poverty issues humanitarian
crisis can often exacerbate uh what's
going on as in the case of covid-19
um you know the world goes out of gear
we've seen that with any emergency so
it's even worse when you have a
humanitarian crisis uh what I think is
is actually depressing but also familiar
about crises such as the rohingya crisis
is that it is also a chronic
long-standing problem we'll talk a
little bit about that in the Q a it's my
great pleasure to welcome Sohail Rahman
so Hill is an award-winning filmmaker
writer and producer he is currently
based in Lisbon Portugal his films has
been screened internationally in various
film festivals and universities around
the world so he'll receive the best
feature documentary film award from the
South Asian Film Festival of Montreal
Canada in 2021
and from the Swede South Asian film
festival Seattle in 2021 for this film
The Ice Cream sellers he also received
the best film award from lucifana
University Lisbon in 2015 for his film a
passagem in the same year he won the
special jury award at the encounters
International Cinema the Vienna film
festival in Portugal born in Chittagong
Bangladesh so its love of visual art
literature and storytelling through him
to filmmaking early in life he teaches
film into French universities and
institutes in Portugal and Bangladesh as
an invited filmmaker he's the director
and chief organizer of mostra the cinema
Lisbon Portugal
so so welcome Sohail it's really an
honor to to have you here talking about
about your film
thank you so much Nila it's an honor to
have me here and my presence and we
screen my phone here thank you so much
thank you and you know I know we have a
few members of the audience of the
audience here but you know I'd really
like to start with uh with you know
question around uh where is um
where is everybody really coming from so
um but if I ask you where you're coming
from you're going to say New Haven so I
really want to know first of all you
know where are our members of the
audience where did you actually grow up
what were your experiences so if you can
put into the chat into the the zoom chat
we currently have which country you grew
up in if there were multiple countries
you grew up and put all of them down I
think it'll give us a sense of what
experiences our audience has had uh
because our experiences inform how we
look at uh things like uh you know like
like drawing Etc so
um you know I'd love to know where you
actually came from so put in your
answers in the chat and let's see what
shows up in the map
so I'm gonna start I will
um
put in my answer I grew up in India
and I think so hail you grew up in
so you can see that's me grew up in
India
um
you don't have to raise your hand just
put your answers down just type out your
answers in the chat
Shanghai it's good to know
[Music]
turkey
Denmark
um USA New York State
um so it's good to know I think we've
got uh people and the reason I think
this is important is because where we
grow up and where we spend our lives
influences and provides us a lens also
into the world I think so
um so it's nice to know that you know
folks have have really come from
um from all over the world and um you
know I'd really like to know also
um have you watched the the movie yet
because if not I think soil can give a
little bit of an introduction to the
movie and we I really hope you'll watch
it I spent uh you know I didn't even
realize an hour in 15 minutes and I had
to sit in silence after that for the
next I think 10 or 15 minutes because no
matter how much you read about something
I think it's when you watch the everyday
lives of people who are going through
that particular situation you can really
sort of understand what's happening so
um again if you can just let me know in
the maybe just put in the Q a uh whether
you've watched the the movie The Ice
Cream sellers
well let me just actually
um
share my screen
um
and um
let me
um this one
[Music]
um
let me do this poll then
okay
so there are three you know just type
one two or three like have you watched
the movie
um if you've seen the whole the whole
movie if you've only partly seen the
movie they started watching 10 minutes
and then you stopped or if you haven't
watched it or not just put in one two or
three on the chat
great Dean yes it was it was really
eye-opening I think so um
yeah that's great so some of you watched
it partly I think
um yeah looks like people have watched
it so well and even though this is a
relatively small group
um
you know it's good to see
yeah so it looks like a lot of you have
watched the the movie it's not long for
the ones who said partly or those who
say no it's just an hour and 15 minutes
uh and I think it's absolutely worth
watching I didn't even do what I
normally do which is to put this on 1.25
speed or one and a half speed because I
think it's really not just the the film
itself but the silences and some of the
scenes that are worth actually taking in
and reflecting on
um so I actually uh hope that you know
everybody has actually sort of watched
um watch the movie or ends up watching
it as a result of our discussion today
and questions that you might have and so
on so uh for those of you who actually
watched the movie
um you know what what sort of again you
can put in the chat what sort of words
would you use to describe and this is I
think Sohail was looking for some
feedback on the movie so my quick
question before we start and I asked him
uh what sort of words would you describe
uh used to describe the ice cream
sellers
you can just put it in the chat
you know four or five of you who have
watched the movie
yeah
I think that was true it was very moving
um I felt the same way
in the other
unfair that's very interesting
um and maybe I'll call on you to talk
about that a little bit
um
just any words that come to mind I know
a lot of words came to mind not all of
them can be repeated because uh like you
I I found it unfair and it made me angry
uh a bit to see you know
to see the unfairness but um any other
words that for those of you who watch
the movie and someone said it was it was
a great experience
um
playful that's interesting yes I think I
got a sense of that as well and you know
maybe we'll probe a little bit with
Sohail uh so hail and that candid
evocative yes
um I think the games and toys really led
to that and so it's kind of an unusual
combination I agree with sort of the
general sentiment here that Not only was
it moving uh but it was also moving
because it was playful and because of
the games and toys so you know in some
ways and we talk a little bit about that
you know what what led sohil to to make
this kind of movie and this particular
lens uh on things that we have but yeah
thank you thank you very much and
um you know I'll sort of stop
um
stock sharing and get to
um you know I hope that was that was
good and you sort of saw a sense of
Sohail even a sense of what the audience
took away from the movie which is what I
took away from the movie This sort of
sense of both being moving and playful
of being
um
astounded is a good word I think uh
astounded by both the resilience but the
matter of factness really came out to me
as well which is that often when people
have suffered so much uh there is just
no way to describe you know the reaction
other than being completely matter of
fact about it and if you actually mute
the sound and you just listen to them
you wouldn't think that they were
talking about you know their husbands or
their sons or their daughters being
killed or raped or mutilated you just
think they were talking about everyday
things and I don't know whether that was
for me that was even more sort of moving
than uh you know than if that had been
drama but I want to come to sort of this
question of what motivated you to make
this film and this particular angle of
using the children and using those
elements of joy and playfulness in the
middle of this this terrible portraying
this atrocity Sohail
okay thank you Nila for giving me a
chance to explain and thank you all
audience who have participated in
chatting and also saying this feedback
um is is a great to hear from all of you
um well first of all when it started
happening in 2017 my mom was calling me
all the time every day was like you know
what's happening here in the North River
because I'm from Chicago and it's not
far from the refugee camp
so in in Bangladesh is a few hours from
my hometown to the refugee camp and we
all of our people from the country uh
Bangladeshi people do when we are to
help whatever they had they extended
help like whoever needed some water or
some food or anything whatever they had
and my mom was saying like oh what are
you doing you have to do something for
them and I felt like yeah I have to do
something and what I can do so I was
following up the news uh what's really
happening in one picture just touch my
heart it just broke my heart the mother
she was carrying two children on her
shoulder and running running fast
towards the Border so it's like I I my
mother doesn't belong to the rohingya
but what would have happened if she
would if she did then I just imagine a
situation that is my mom and carrying
two of my me and my siblings and also
running towards border and I can't
imagine that you know
I just felt like okay so I have to do
something as a as a human as a as a
filmmaker so I flew from Lisbon to
Chittagong and I went to that refugee
camp and started filming so first of all
I was like a little bit lost because
there's too much for for someone to to
to endure all those happening all those
suffering or you see the people wounded
people women and is is a cry and
traumatized they almost lost everything
like even the sense and normal
sensibility so when they were talking
they feel like like talking they were
they were narrating
they were describing a killing like they
have it they have breakfast like they
are talking about the breakfast they're
talking something like usual things you
know this I saw this that they lost this
is then I was I was kind of distracted
with the storytelling because I cannot
just shoot randomlys I need a story to
tell and I just felt like no I have to
tell this story because I have this
access and I know they are I know the
dialect what they speak and it's very
very essential for a filmmaker when you
go there and you you cannot just tell
their story if you don't have the
accents we don't have the the same
language or same empathy or like or the
suffering or pain and in that case I
first couple of days I spent for my
research like okay what would be my film
what would be my story and I didn't want
to make a conventional Refugee film I
know there are a lot of film and
everybody understands okay it's a cry is
a suffering so what else we need and I
just decided okay my theme of The Firm
would be something like
after after this massive Massacre
Bloodshed after all this losing their
country their Homeland their loved one
so a community how they can really
survive as a human
so I I just saw everywhere there are
children children children children
you see children children are children
wherever they are still they have this
irrepressible the spirit laughter
happiness even though the weakness they
saw everything but still they have this
spirit of children and they are trying
to make
make make their childhood they're trying
to create their own childhood wherever
they are and then I was like okay so
maybe it would be nice to have the
perspective through the like a
post-genocide period Through The Eyes of
children
how because those children they are hope
they are dream they are the power for
this community that's what I felt then I
started like okay this is the story then
I needed to find out someone like to
carry to guide me to to lead the
storyline the spine of the story then uh
through several encounter I found ayas
and Asia these little siblings and I
asked them what are you doing and having
ice cream then okay so you are selling
ice cream why are you selling ice cream
because we need to make money why you
need to make money then they said okay I
have to give this money to my mom and
what are you your mom what she's going
to do with this money because our father
is in prison in Myanmar and if we send
some bright money to the officials in
Myanmar in prison so that our father can
get release so this is their hope
and they keep trying every day this is
such a huge work it's very hard even I
was with my camera and I was with my
camera I was getting tired it's so dusty
so hot the camp is is never ending
village like you are you keep walking
and you you just need and is I was
amazed I was like oh my God how the
power of these kids have
they are incredible though so they just
moved me and then I chose these children
to to go on with this and I asked them
if I can if they allow me to film and I
said you don't have to do anything and
you just you just let me know
to film you to follow you that's it I
need so every day they go I I go with
them and they stop one door another door
I stop and I feel I face several people
and I encounter those people and they
tell me the story there are several
testimonies so I didn't put everything
in the film and I tried it's it's very
hard also in the in the post-production
time because which one is more important
which one is like I have to make a
balance because it's so heavy things and
I can't deal with this with heaviness I
needed to make it a bit lighter and I
see this this is the one on one hand we
have horroring tale of parents on the
other hand the children they are
laughter their Joy
so that's what yeah sorry that's you
know fantastic and I think that uh I
just want to call attention to one thing
that you said which I think is so true
so this movie hit particularly hard for
me because in a previous life I worked
with Unilever uh which sells ice creams
you know quality walls Upon Us of Brands
and I was actually uh responsible for
ice cream sales in a part of North India
and I think what you said is completely
true about its very hard work uh one of
the things that I was just thinking
about is also um you know if you don't
sell the ice creams enough they melt so
this is not a product like selling chips
or selling you know something which will
last for the next day you have to sell
what you started at the beginning of the
day by the end of the day otherwise it's
useless and I'm sure the person that
they are buying the ice creams from will
charge them if you know they have unsold
ice cream so it's also very you know
holding that box uh I was really
wondering how how the the little boy was
actually sort of holding the box and
going around so easily it's it's heavy
and it's you know it's insulated and
it's uh it's very hard work and yet they
seem to do it very matter-of-factly so
and I do think that what you said came
true very clearly in terms of the
joyfulness and the playfulness
contrasted you know with the subject
being so heavy
um and I noticed that he used that in a
number of places but before that you
know there's a very interesting question
from CC young which is I so held your
documentary is really powerful can you
give us a bit of background about the
meaning of ice cream and ice in the area
where you shot the documentary
um you know especially there was a lot
of imagery about people taking uh baths
you know bucket Parts washing their
bodies with water so was there something
there that connected it or how did you
get on
um you know the story of the kids
selling ice cream we saw a lot of other
vendors someone was selling earrings
someone was selling balloons of course
they're adult vendors but how did you
how do you get into was there anything
specific about the ice cream or just um
it was just one of those uh well these
These Eyes when I was I was working I
was filming thanks for the for the
question is it's very very interesting
question and uh I would love to talk
about this because it was very hot and
they don't have any power any
electricity and they don't have any
fridge any in cold water and I was
sweating even me when I was with the
film with the camera and everybody was
is very the the shelter of the is not a
home but the shelter of the the fish
energy cam in the camp so it's very very
dusty and hot so they don't have any any
cold water or anything even also they're
not surrounded by trees or green things
now it is growing these days but when I
was filming it's right after the
genocide it's very new very fresh that
time
I just felt like wow this ice cream
these these kids they are not just
selling ice cream it's something they
are putting a piece a little piece of of
of of uh cold water is like a piece
giving them peace in that heart in that
burning fire so you give a little water
like they needed something so it's a
that's why these kids bringing the Hope
through this ice cream they have nothing
that but they offer you something and
that's a piece of ice cream but that's a
metaphor a big that box the that the
holes on the shoulder they hold their
life they are like taking that you know
that's that's that's moved me a lot so I
also I tried several titles for the film
but then I was like no I wanted to make
it simple and and short so I choose ice
cream sellers is a title of the film
yeah and um and I think that's your film
it's it's simple on the surface but it's
got a lot of layers once you sort of
unpeel the surface uh you know it seems
like a simple tale and I did notice that
at the beginning of the film you have
this very Lush sort of green uh you know
as they're fleeing I think that's a
shorter very lush green fields and then
uh and then when I saw the you know the
camp it's you're right it's very dusty
there's in fact halfway through I
realized there's not even a single tree
in this Camp it's just all like dust and
it's brown baked and it just brought me
to mind of you know how it's not just
about being in in a refugee camp which
is hard enough but it's where you
actually are to be just stripped of
Nature and in such a difficult situation
must just add to the difficulties you
know one thing I noticed Sohail in the
in the movie which really struck me was
that um in this temporary area of you
know temporary living
um people maintain such good rules so
you know how fatro is wondering there
are two little kids taking ice creams
anyone can just sort of snatch their ice
cream box right or not pay for the ice
creams and yet every transaction you
know people haggle like they bargain in
any Market uh you know he the the the
kid says I won't get my profit if I sell
so many it was a very normal interaction
it wasn't you know what we often think
about in Conflict situations which is
that people will lose all sense of
um you know what day-to-day interactions
look like so it looked like a normal
Market transaction if you hadn't told me
that it was in a refugee camp you know
can you say something from your
experience with filming in terms of this
kind of observation in terms of rules of
the camp or rules of interaction uh
during this time of you know was it
surprising was it no actually it's not
surprising because when a group of
people get together and they've been
living somewhere for five years maybe
they need to have certain rules
otherwise the whole thing would be
generated into chaos but you know what
was what was surprise rising to you
about the about you know the situation
that you were not expecting when you
went into making the film
there are lots of things and
I think every every day when I go to the
camp to to shoot
and
it's because most of the people I mean
they don't have any cash money and the
rights that they received from the aid
International Aid organization so they
get it every day or in a week or somehow
and they have they they have this
collection of rice so but that's also
important and they are waiting everybody
they have nothing to do just traumatize
that's like exhausted with the weight of
trauma and then they exchange this with
the rice but you know
they are on one side they lost
everything and they are sensibility they
are sympathy is it's it's a it's a
fluctuated it's like okay I saw
everything all the horrible things
happen to me before my eyes I saw my son
got killed I saw so many how come I can
survive anymore they lost the normal
sensibility so every day when I go to
the I go to the camp to film then I say
I beg I can't sleep anymore because I
especially the mother who was who was at
the end you saw she was crying like she
couldn't control anymore and she was
hugging the tree and she thought I look
like I resemble her her son and I it was
very heartbreaking I couldn't really
control even my camera I was asking
myself should I roll my camera or should
I just give her a hug I wanted to give
her a hug but you know this also there
is a cultural problem like you cannot
hug a woman like
in that in that corner of the world some
somehow if you are a stranger but it's
like it feels my heart is burning was
burning when I was encountering was
interviewing her it's not interview I
just asked her what was the story and
then and also every day I meet them is
it's not I didn't keep a profile as a
filmmaker
I went there I didn't use any crew
member I was alone with a little camera
with a Canon 5D Mark II and I put a
microphone on the camera so I didn't so
people are not afraid and they don't
have any pressure to impress me
to like okay this is the fourth
television for the film no so it was
very natural and I wanted to go under
the surface I wanted to feel their pain
in the in my camera and also personally
and it's it's shocking every day I
couldn't sleep for a long time and I was
I was also having tough time then it was
those kids they were a massive source of
inspiration for me and I saw I learned
from them wow these they are doing this
and I have to do I have to keep going
even in life we have so many trouble
happens but look at these kids they have
nothing but there is still nothing they
are still moving forward so I get
inspired out of their their their work
how they work how they how they live
there every day and there are several
characters one one guy
who was selling he was selling something
uh I think vegetables and he he he sold
everything and he tried to buy some
balloons for his kids and he couldn't
afford that he tried to bargain
something
and he couldn't afford and the balloon
sellers they are also tough because they
are also selling balloons and is is also
they have to buy it with the monies they
don't have enough money to be kind to
this guy and they are also very harsh
and they're they're just like no we
cannot make it for you and there they
are gone and this guy is is just waiting
and just looking to the balloon I was
like oh my God and he came and he was
counting the money and every day there
are other other women who were saying
how they got raped the wounds but it is
too much for for the audience for
international audience to to show this
but personally it was very shocking for
me
and you know it's it's interesting that
you say it's it's too much for the
international audience to be seen to be
shown right because it is actually
reality and here we are actually saying
well reality might be too harsh for
those of us who are fortunate and lucky
to escape that reality so uh in some
ways it's actually worse than I hear you
saying you know it's much much worse
than what uh what can transaction and
what has been shown uh and I do want to
make a point about what you talked about
which is the resilience you know um I
noticed that scene as well and it was
striking for uh you know for two reasons
one is as you said
um like a normal Market transaction you
know you might work very hard and then
not be able to afford something right we
see this issue with deprivation all the
time those of us who are fortunate
enough we still feel deprived with you
know I can't afford this particular
thing is but it's even worse and it's
probably probably even more you know
exacerbated in a in a conflict and
humanitarian situation because you've
really lost everything and time and time
again
um there were people in the film who
talked about how much they had lost and
really you know that and and there was
the scene I think right after that where
the person says you know we should just
buy balloons for the children because uh
you know they should just be happy and
um and and I think that's that's really
interesting because you know in normal
situations we teach children to wait for
things and to sort of you know have
self-control but in this situation how
can you really deny whatever little
happiness you get when life is uncertain
um I do think it uh there was another
scene similarly where someone said we
just pretend we're on holiday in this
Camp because we don't want to believe
that this is reality and it's really
um you know there is a lot of work to be
done I think uh to understand mental
health consequences uh and how people
cope with this kind of situation because
it's not just a situation of loss it's a
situation of uncertainty and we know
that in times of uncertainty you know
people COPE in very different ways so uh
just as we're discussing you know what
is it that we need to know I think that
certainly there were a few places that I
felt oh we should really understand what
the consequences of of being in the camp
are you know the uncertainty
sort of idea that I lost something
um you know at the end of the movie you
talked about uh sort of the current
situation uh when when exactly did you
film this because you talked about
covid-19 actually impacting the
situation can you talk a little bit
about that
um and you know if you've gone back or
heard anything since then what the
situation has been like
okay so it's it's I I filmed right after
the channel side when they are they're
coming so it was in 2017. so I kept in
touch but I after filming I was there
for three months then I came back to
Portugal and I was editing but when my
in my post-production time I had to put
this okay that that led the situation
was really happening and then we see uh
and that the trial in the international
court of justice icj in the hag that
also discovered happening then there was
no hope and I was still in contact with
them what's happening your father is
back no and there is no hope and there
were and slowly they were getting out of
out of the headline and there are no
more headlines and there nobody is
talking about that so now is it's
terrible what's uh is is also hard for
me to have the access because there is
no no no mobile phone no network inside
inside the camp so it's I couldn't
really continue keep in touch with them
but I know some of my friends who are
working there
and also some of the of the refugee
rohingya people so I'm in touch with
them and I'm asking what's really
happening and they'll keep me updated
about the situation which is really uh
is is also shocking because every day is
getting less they don't have any more
education rights of education so they
don't really before there was some sort
of education and now it's getting more
worse and so the aid is getting less
every day that there is no education and
also that the the people they are
getting more desperate so they are
escaping from the camp by legal ways so
sometimes that we see the news on the
the they are they died in the river
because they were trying to escape
trying to go somewhere Indonesia or
Malaysia or India and is horrible and
then know that what's really
consequences coming for in their life
but they don't care and they said like
what else we have to do because when I
was I was filming I couldn't put every
statement every testimony but there were
people who are dreaming that one day we
go back and I get married one day we go
like the children or they're saying
what's happening with the mango trees
and that's another shocking scene for me
like when the children they were I was
filming something else and suddenly I
saw
them they're having this uh the the
situation is is um the head hope there
after even after the genocide when they
came and they were still expecting they
will go back International Community
will help and to to secure their basic
human rights and also to citizenship
rights to go back there and and before
the reaper creation so there was
sometimes there was something like uh
one time I remember through the U.N they
tried to make a repatriation for a small
amount of people but they said we prefer
to get buried with funeral rather than
going just going there and kill them get
buried and if we stay here we get
funeral we if you go there we would not
get them so that's very you know they
care about these things and the things
what's happening in Myanmar right now
also not very pleasing and is also still
ongoing genocide yesterday I saw a video
clip from from a rohingya person he was
also saying like look it's we are not
happy we are in here stuck in the in the
region in the rakhanstead and is still
another ongoing genocide it's uh so
International Community he was asking to
give give some attention to them try to
help them yeah and I do want to add here
that uh you know neither Sohail nor I
are experts in international
humanitarian law but uh on March 21st
2022 following a rigorous factual and
legal analysis the Secretary of State
actually of the United States determined
that members of the Burmese military
committed genocide and crimes against
humanity against rohingya and the United
States has concluded only seven other
times since the Holocaust that genocide
was committed so this determination was
the eighth so
there are various you know terms that
are used and and various ways to
classify atrocities against humanity but
I just wanted to put that out there I
think one of the related questions Paul
Sarno asked is do the camp residents
know about the lawsuit before the icj
and all the other suits what are they
aware of you know taking from Paul's
question what are they actually aware of
what the outside world is is thinking or
doing in this regard
uh well the most some people know some
people following that but you know is uh
most of the people that you don't have
proper education or academic education
for a long time because it's a slow
poisoning for a long time when the the
Myanmar government taking out these uh
the citizenship right and they didn't
have access to the school maybe they
finish primary school or elementary
school then they didn't have access to
the university so they couldn't really
continue their education so what's
really happening most of the big most of
them are either fishermen or just farmer
or doing something else to make their
living
and now is is more they don't have that
fresh air anymore they are like in an
open-air prison and is is is a different
circumstances and they don't have they
are not very aware like in in terms of
General rohingya but there are some
people who are who are connected with
network or somehow they are they are
working for any NGO so they have sort of
knowledge what's really happening about
the lawsuit and uh with the the icj and
sometimes they celebrate that Gambia was
helping that The Gambia was standing for
them so it it goes viral in in the in
the refugee camp so everybody knows that
but not really like knowing about law
and and the rights not everybody because
yeah everybody but maybe there are some
some changes now
yeah no and uh if there are uh the any
of the audience members as uh you know
much more in-depth knowledge of
humanitarian uh or international law
please feel free to actually share that
knowledge on the chat uh Paul also asked
the related I think quite difficult
question which is it's clear that it's
unlikely they will be able to go back to
Myanmar if that is correct which
countries do you think that they will go
or do we have any idea and I just put
this in perspective you know the the
statistic that actually shocked me was
to learn that there were almost a
million refugees and I looked up the
population of New Haven Connecticut
where Yale University is around 130 000
people in all of New Haven so this is
kind of like eight times the population
of New Haven
um you know and New Haven is the third
largest uh city or town in Connecticut
in one of the states so you know so that
just puts into perspective just how big
this it's not question of a few hundred
refugees and I think very similar to
other long-standing camps
Etc the question I think is where would
they go right I understand they've been
effectively they're stateless in that
sense uh they're not recognized as
Citizens I think the big question is is
there any sort of um update or
understanding or negotiation about where
they would go
um okay so I I just followed some news
and there was a foreign minister of
Bangladesh he was trying to trying to
talk with China with India because this
is also going to be a a regional threat
what is happening this Refuge young
youngsters they are growing up and as
lots of children I think it's a 30 000
children uh every year
some there is an I forgot the exact
number but it's something like that and
so is what's really happening and is
going to be if if you're not providing
education if you're not providing any
basic human rights and everything is
getting like more more more smaller more
words then they'll get more desperate
and they will be used by other other
criminals for example for the especially
for the drugs and that that was that
area is very famous for for the drugs
dealing because of the river because of
the sea and there was uh something
happening and it's not just for the
Bangladesh but also it's a is a is a
regional threat for India for Myanmar
for Bangladesh for Thailand for other
countries who are sharing the same area
so and that's why they have like all the
government they should really take uh
necessary steps a very like useful
things not just talking and last the on
25th or 24th of August I had I was
sharing a panel with a conversation with
the foreign minister of Malaysia he he
also said very like they are very
welcoming to rohingya Refugee but also
already there they have some people
there with the rohingya community a big
community of Moringa they are living in
Malaysia so far what I talked to the
Royal also in India also in Indonesia
there are few numbers and we I know some
people who are living in the U.S but not
that big amounts it's it's not it's not
that effective yeah what is uh what
concern I can't say like uh uh did the
if that is correct to what countries do
you think they will go
I mean they still prefer to go to
Myanmar
they they have they are just not
refugees they are a group of people with
past with honor with with the with
culture and now they lost everything and
there is anything that is still saying
that like the people they are the the
the the the the the people who are
saying like we are just socializing we
feel like we have to feel like we are on
holiday you know that guy was was after
the interview who was he was with full
of tears because he said I had too many
Honda motorbikes and I was very rich
person I was very respected person now I
have nothing to do I have I lost
everything
and I think yeah sorry I just wanted I
didn't mean to interrupt you but uh I
just wanted to say that uh uh I we I
don't think we often realize that
refugees in humanitarian camps can't
work they're not allowed to work so this
is not like a migration scenario where
people go to another country and they
can work even now I think the government
is deciding whether they can work and I
think you refer to it in in the drug
violence and again you know the way
people are coping with it is to say we
are here on a holiday we are socializing
but in addition to income there's also a
loss of identity if you know people get
a lot of their meaning in life from
working and if they just can't work uh
they can you know obviously get
desperate for income but also a lot of
their sense of what it means to uh you
know be a useful person in society
because that's the way we've always
talked about people right that you
should work for a living and you know
when you can't do that there are a lot
of issues that I think will come to the
for you're completely right in terms of
you know these effects of violence and
and other uh sort of abuses because
people are just not allowed to work I
mean imagine if any of us were told
tomorrow I think we'd be happy for maybe
a day or two and then we'd start getting
restless so imagine when you're told for
long periods of time that you know your
status is so uncertain not allowed to
work so um yeah I think uh when I heard
that person talking you could very
clearly see that he wasn't saying it
very joyfully he was almost saying it in
a very resigned fashion you know what
can we do we can socialize here
yeah oh I think a good question is uh
you know that comes up is uh and and
this is a tricky question right because
again this is very different from
chronic poverty in that uh people need
to know information about their rights
and a lot of people in the documentary
also talked about their rights they
talked about you know getting back their
rights
um so the ngos that help in uh the
rohingya and the camps disseminate
information about rights or do they
support them on more of the health care
and other basic necessities uh do you
see more of uh I know you know the uh
the humanitarian agencies have set up
and there are different areas that they
help in education Healthcare
um is there a way that there are people
are educated about their rights so you
think that's not yet happening in in the
camps
a uh well so far I know with my little
knowledge I think there are some some
organizations who are working for that
but this is not really enough for for
this and as is on formal schools are
closed so there is no no even school so
it's it's getting because Bangladesh has
this uh what I learned they are saying
like is is is is it refugee camp we
can't we can't give them like a home
like like giving the education and
everything so they will stay longer they
would not go back home so that's what I
I realized through to the different kind
of explanation from different corner but
what I feel is is very important to to
to let them know their basic rights
information about health about the the
birth control and because it's also like
really happening and they said like if
if God creates there are also
misconcepts because they are not they
are because of the lack of knowledge
that they depends on on something like
spiritual power something like God's
like you know these mostly they are
devoted to the religion but at the same
time they don't they have no any any
kind of uh material or any other other
education I'm please don't get offended
other people who I'm not against
religion but I'm saying that because
they have a way they have a saying that
oh okay if God creates the children God
will take care of them
you know so there but at the end of the
day you have to go you have to ask for
food for your children you can't just
you know this is something that have
misconception about so many things about
way of living about their health their
the other system other disease is also
and I think yeah of course that
government Bangladesh government at the
same time some other NGO or the
organization they should take care of it
more
there's a good point to think about
which is that it's not just about uh
providing the health and uh and the
basic necessities but you know again as
we talked about work work is not just
about the money that you get it's also
your chance to be a sort of productive
member of the society so it contributes
to your identity similarly you know it's
not only about giving people health care
and basic necessities uh but also
telling people about their rights right
treating them like equal human beings
and really sort of recognizing their
dignity even in this situation so it's a
really important sometimes we can forget
that when we are so as you know
all of us who are in service of of the
folks in forget it because we think oh
if we give give people you know help
then that's enough but we forget that
you know people are people we are full
human beings we want our dignity to be
affirmed you know whatever we do and
that is the ability to work the ability
to have freedom to move to you know know
our rights to fight for our rights and
however people might say well why don't
you compromise or adjust you know if I
feel very strongly I should be allowed
to express that so I think that's that
came up a little bit because I was
surprised not surprised but I think it
was very reflective that despite all of
what they've seen they still talked
about we want our rights you know we
want to go back and we want our rights
otherwise there's no point in going back
so they were not prepared to just go
back you know just like that they said
only if our full rights are restored to
us um since we had a question about what
the mother was doing while the kids sold
ice cream do you know
um
she mentioned a younger child was was
very younger child also we I don't think
we saw the young whichever but she
mentioned towards the end I wasn't sure
okay so I was uh I was also wondering
what she was really doing and then I
asked her but she said she takes care of
them and she tried to get some work but
she didn't get any work but she
completely depends on the income of of
their of her kids earning every day so
and she takes care of other other
children you see like one two three four
four of them and she has more kids two
more yeah they are not there so yeah I
mean is most of the women they are like
that and uh and I think again it's
another thing when you know we talk
about setting up refugee camps it's not
as simple as giving people some housing
and giving them some food what happens
is societal inequalities sort of also
the same thing happens right so if uh if
if women have not been used to sort of
earning their own living or doing
something or people are not used to
employing them they're not going to
employ them in just because it's now a
refugee camp so we've got to think about
you know what were they doing before
what are people's you know social norms
about what women can and can't do and
you know uh what needs to be done and
you know in this context I want to say
that uh advice we're conducting some
research in Cox's uh Bazaar with the
World Bank and other institutions and uh
and one of the things is to understand
violence against women uh you know
understand someone talked about I think
I should talked about how children how
inequalities impact children's life I
think we're trying to understand how
such
conditions impact things like violence
against women which is uh you know is it
worse is it better because everyone's
now in a shared situation is it worse
because there's so much frustration uh
has it become worse as people are uh
there for a longer time because if you
have to do is it different from uh you
know violence against women in chronic
poverty situations or is there something
about this particular situation that's
different because only if we understand
that we can understand you know what's
happening
um I do want to encourage the audience
to post any more questions in uh in the
Q a and also maybe you know in terms of
at least my final uh question uh maybe
to Sohail but also to the audience which
is
um you know as a filmmaker what's their
expectation of what you know centers of
learning like like Yale and the
university can actually do in this uh
you know giant problem we are not
governments and we are not uh you know
ngos who are directly going to be there
but there is a role that universities
can actually play uh you know in in
maybe you know getting attention to
these atrocities what do you see as a
sort of the role and very similar I
guess what's your role as a filmmaker uh
you know in in highlighting some of
these things so that others have
awareness of it
okay uh so I let's see if there is some
audience that says something I would
love some audience reactions what do you
think is the role of you know of
universities like Yale in terms of uh
you know this you can put it in the Q a
and I'll just pick it up from there but
what do you think is the role of
universities in
um in humanitarian crises like this what
what can we do
uh is I I can't tell you like what you
should do but I can't I can tell you my
expectation like maybe you are the right
person what you can do you can tell
about these uh from the University
perspective or from the academic
perspective but like like if you go with
the with the anthropology like
malinoisky who went to for the field
work so he brought something we didn't
know but then we started from this
armchair anthropology then it's breaks
and this but I'm saying
and the kind of University a center a
research center a university if they
talk about this it it means a lot for
them for example right now is there are
people engagement there are we are
talking you are talking so is already a
lot for for these one of the most
persecuted communities in the world and
there are like almost International
Community has forgotten about them and
now a university is one of the top most
universities in the world yes and they
are that I I'm really grateful and
thankful to you to to the university
that invited my film and screening for
the big audience especially for the
academic world and I think it has a
significant impact
especially for making the awareness and
also it's for the future and future
people will know that and it will it
will help to prevent another genocide in
another corner of the world
if we if we have some some research why
it's happening what should you do and
some suggestion some writing some film
more films more reviews more more things
so it's I think everybody whatever we
have the ability we should talk about
this we should go for this we should do
anything so that's what I feel as a
filmmaker maybe I'm not I'm I I I just
tried a little contribution it's not but
what I'd be happy to see someday that's
there are lots of people that said well
this is something what we needed to see
in in France I was it was in person
screening in France in Toulouse when I
screen the film and some people had to
leave because they couldn't
they couldn't digest they couldn't
continue because it's too much for them
and then some people just came to me and
just gave me a hug and started crying
then saying oh my God we didn't have any
idea what's happening that in that
corner of the world we just saw some
news and that's it so because the medium
like newspaper or the television or the
journalistic work I appreciate lots of
great journalists that went there they
did a great great journalism the the the
picture they portrayed the the
sufferings and everything but still they
have somehow
they are not free there is always like
editorial policy of the newspaper or is
it policy so University in terms of
University they have this freedom of
research they have this freedom of of
raising the voice in an authentic way
honest and genuinely and then I think
the University of Mall University I'm so
grateful to some other universities they
also invited me almost now 15
universities around the world they
invited me with this film and I'm I'm
looking forward to the U.S trip where
I'm going to screen my film in UCLA
NYU and USC Barclay and there are lots
of universities we are talking like
every day so that's what I I as a
filmmaker with this film I would like to
tell this story to the world and to feel
it not just giving the information but
to feel and to fly with this pain that's
what I want and I think thank you to be
part of the journey
thank you I think that um
um there is one more question but I just
want to make a note about the role of
University so we talked a little bit
about you know the label of genocide and
when that label is applied and when it's
not applied and it might just seem that
oh we are sitting here you know and
uncomfortable
um studies and libraries and
universities and offices and deciding
whether to call something but I think
labels provide legitimacy and
universities do the same thing which I
hear you saying they provide a platform
they provide a legitimacy to say this is
real
um you know this is important this is
something we should pay attention to and
I think that makes a lot of um you know
that that makes a lot in terms of moving
uh World opinion forward I also think
your point about freedom of research is
extremely important uh you know
universities have freedom to research
things that
um you know that that might be
uncomfortable but need to be actually
revealed so it's a very I think
important and quite you know or inspired
writing responsibility that we do have
as a university you've made the film
you've really touched the hearts of
people you brought out the reality as a
filmmaker you've made this reality Vivid
to people
also universities are engaged in
teaching young people uh I think you
know what do we do to avoid the next
such atrocity uh what have we learned
and and I think in in the light of
discussions about you know the liberal
arts and learning from history I think
you know it really is important to think
about uh the role of centers of learning
in in something uh about this and
um there's one more question actually uh
that we had about the film from CC that
I noticed that you only shoot the upper
body of the man who lost his legs it
seems that you don't want to sell
miseries and you talk to them a little
bit about
um can you tell us a bit about your
thinking process of making that shot and
even I realized that and I was like wait
a minute this he doesn't have his legs
were shot I mean he looks from the from
the angle that you've shot him he looks
actually quite healthy and you know very
well to do can you tell us a little bit
about the thinking process in terms of
making that making the shot
well is there are several shorts like
that and then I I always try to to deal
with respect with with the compassion
with respect and I really felt it's not
just for the Cinematic Journey but also
as a person and I didn't as I'm saying
even I was having problem if I should
put the the mother crying then finally I
I choose to to to keep it in the film
and there are other other more horrible
charts like really is is too much that's
way for the for the international
audience maybe the people who already
saw there is is usual for them and for
even some people will say oh this is
nothing if they see my film they will
say oh this is nothing in terms of
what's really happening to them so I
tried to have these people and in my
framing I was following mostly
observational and then is is I'm
grateful to all those people who allow
me to film them and I also didn't really
want to embarrass them in terms of doing
something and I didn't want to take
disadvantages maybe in cinematic way it
could be great but I left in some some
some some shots because it doesn't work
in terms of Ethics in terms of crack
Aesthetics so I I try to make like that
way and then of course as I'm saying is
it's a very tough it's hard work it's
it's very it's very dark at the same
time it's it's a pain it's a tragedy
it's a loss then I'm and I how can I
deal it at the for a long time it took
long time in terms of editing but also
in terms of when I was filming every day
and I tried to be very respectful and
and passionate and to them and they
understand it because the if you see the
all the people who were talking to the
camera or talking to me you see their
eyes and those eyes you you that they
can't lie if you see their eyes so it's
then I try to make this eyes to the
audience to to see their eyes as there
was I was I was I was reading a review
an article from from the Myanmar
perspective and they said oh they're
lying those people are lying
those are just a lie the false statement
and that was really like no come on how
can how come these people can lie with
me and they're with full of tears with
that old man the old man who had like
two men who are sitting together
I lost my father he he I I found like
eggs and another father of me and when
he was talking he's he lost everything
but the way that the the the the the
words the choice of his words intonation
and everything was so respectful so
humble and also it shows his personality
and he he lost everything but still the
guy is is quite controlled and I was
really amazed oh my God these these
people are how how they can bear this
wound inside them
no it's a it's a great point you raised
about uh
how do you depict suffering without sort
of exploiting people suffering you know
there's been a lot of backlash in the
NGO world around what is called poverty
Pawn which is depicting people in
extreme suffering and it really is a
difficult choice on the one hand you do
want to show that you don't want to
sugarcoat reality but on the other hand
uh you know uh both from the perspective
of sort of keeping people's agency and
also what um you know chimamanda
the danger of a single story these
people are people who have fled their
homes and their Refuge you know they are
now refugees in a camp but that's not
only who they are they're also children
they're also ice cream sellers they're
also balloon sellers they're also you
know so I think you've done a great job
in sort of not just focusing on only all
of the suffering or trying to exploit
that I think it's a very fine line that
any film so you know I thought that was
very well done
and yes you know as srija said the role
of the University with the help of
filmmakers is to show what is happening
to document what is actually happening
but to document it as I said not just in
a way that shows only one story or one
part it's all only suffering but to show
the the full reality of what is
happening right how human beings COPE in
such situations the good the bad so that
we can have a sort of a better response
I'm going to throw it open uh if there
are other questions that our audience
has or comments
um and then maybe ask your final sort of
question so hail in terms of anything
else that you would like to say given
that you know you have this time and uh
you know this will be shown not just to
the audience right now but to to the
broader audience I think Kathy had a
question
um which is oh yes this was an
interesting one have you been able to
screen the film at the camp itself uh
were you able to go back and she and and
also my add-on question to that is have
you been able to share the responses to
the film with the with your with the
people who are in the film yeah well uh
unfortunately not yet but I would love
to do that and try it and now next year
I'm planning to go there and to screen
the film and maybe I will I will follow
up I will make another film what's
really happening after the five years
and I have to find them because I lost
their track since the mobile because I
was only medium was mobile so I was
getting touched and then I lost them now
I would really love to show the film to
them and and also having the feedback
what they really love but what I can
tell you when I was showing I was
filming every day and then at the end of
the day that all the keys they become
like my friends you know and they follow
me and then I was showing them from my
camera like hey look how you look like
and then oh show me show me more okay so
it's funny it's a place and it's so so
so nice I I forget that memory that's uh
that's good and I hope you have a chance
to uh you know um to actually show this
more widely even to those who are
actually uh in in the camp I think
another question that was asked us is
the documentary filmmaker and I think
this is a little bit of what we are
discussing like how do you balance the
telling of the stories while trying to
be considerate of not bringing out any
trauma so we talked about you know not
exploiting people but also just having
people relate their trauma can be
triggering for them I think of the
mother who lost her son and the child
who was talking about how things would
be better when his father was back so
how do you deal with the situation of
asking people to recount their trauma
but also sort of playing that balancing
role with making sure that you know you
don't bring out any more trauma
uh so is is a very significant question
that's how I'm trying to evolve I'm
trying to improve myself as a filmmaker
it's not just with the rohingya but if
you look uh my other words like I did my
with the two Portuguese Shepherd ladies
or Shepherd women they are 85 and 87
years old they work in the middle of
nowhere I'm a guy from Bangladesh and
they have ever never heard about the
country and they have no idea what is
Bangladeshi it's something like that for
them is a different planet like a Moon
or Sun or something like that so they
have a tragedy the women the the
shepherd lady idolina I call her grandma
and she lost her husband he was also
Shepherd by a car crash and the guy who
made the car crash
Ed he is asking money for the damage of
his car
he is such a trauma and she she moved
from one city to other City to work and
all his she was living with her husband
and they were they were okay with
shepherd with the with animals and
everything but then she has to carry
this trauma losing her husband and then
on the is another pain that someone is
knocking the door asking the money for
the damage of his car
I ask like okay I know this is the film
but I have to deal it with very very
smoothly very tenderly and then we found
I didn't want her she was crying she was
like because with my Portuguese back
then my Portuguese was not good but I
was doing my Masters in 2012 and 14 came
from a Belgium then to do this then it
was because what I tried to do is I try
to let them know myself and explore like
okay there is a universal language there
is an access a kind of unread and a bond
between filmmaker and the character
especially when you are doing a creative
documentary so if because that that if
the the character if the people who we
are filming if they don't if they have
some confusion if they don't trust you
you would never get a proper you would
never get a genuine story and you would
never possible it's not impossible to
make a good film in terms of that so the
trauma is always like when we deal this
pain and normally my films comes from
pain my films mostly like tragedy laws
pain and all this kind of work is I
don't know how it's uh I I go with this
kind of film and I I get inspired and I
make it and I so with this grandma she
was I just I just gave her a situation
to unfold to reveal what's really our
universe is and then she started
revealing naturally without just asking
how your husband got killed and how it
was happened and did you were you very
sad and no I didn't ask anything I just
let her talk and all those people when I
was filming in the camp in the refugee
camp
I just said how are you how was your day
how how do you feel what what were you
thinking so it started from very simple
simple question and then it's it's
connected linked with something else and
then when it comes out and either they
smile or they cry or or they just normal
and there is there is one woman I she
was saying she was pregnant and then I
have I I put in in one version of the
film she was pregnant and I was asking
her what are you doing she asked me to
film her and her child inside her and
she said are you excited yes I'm excited
and then where is her his father and
then he was slaughtered
so that where she was responding is like
like telling that she had a breakfast or
something you know how these people this
mental trauma
these these laws this tragedy made these
people like this level of like kind of
they lost everything they are no more
human they are not sick but is is they
live in different level of uh I I can't
explain
properly with my words but for me the
film is good for to explain the things
and then this is how I normally handle
and sorry that I can I read the acting
um yeah no it was really about balancing
the
The Balancing Act that you have to make
as a filmmaker between telling the story
and sort of triggering the trauma when
people are telling you the story
yes so that's then we go with the with
the with the with the like when we have
food what we we see like we we don't go
for everything at the same time so we
have like uh we choose our our choice
our taste so in the the same thing if I
could put
I I could put all all kind of injury
wounds and more suffering more things it
would not be accepted as it is now it
would not touch a big community
it would not touch like okay this is
maybe maybe it could touch but it's it's
Grand it's like you will understand okay
this filmmaker is just trying to make me
sad yeah but that's not my view that's
not what I'm trying to see I'm trying to
do and uh and I do want to add one more
thing which is I think that you know we
need to make sure that when that we
treat people's responses in the
situation as precious right and that's
why it's important that you've taken the
trouble to build that trust you talked
about trust which takes a long time to
build and ask them questions very
vulnerable questions and it's our
responsibility then to share it as
widely as possible so we don't have 50
people all descending on the camp with
the same idea and keeping on asking the
same questions over and over again I
think that if we have people who are
going in and who are sort of building
trust with the communities there and who
are asking these questions and getting
responses I think we should you know our
responsibility is to share that
information as much as possible and I do
want to say for example at waira as I
mentioned this a little bit but we are
doing some research collecting data
around consumption and among other
things and starting out with the you
know things like what is the extent of
violence against women but also maybe
looking at other questions so on and one
of the things we want to do is um we're
going to be in the data collection
process in October November uh have you
know have the data in early next year
and share that data widely so that we
don't have you know a constant stream of
researchers who are going in there and
saying oh I must ask my question because
you know this is a particular case where
you can't keep asking people a hundred
times over and over again it's not just
that people will get tired it's it's
also that people don't want to keep
talking about the trauma over and over
again so we should be respectful and I
think one of our big duties is to make
sure that we are not duplicating
research or storytelling so that uh you
know we are respectful of people sort of
time and what they're going through when
they provide answers to these questions
so I'm glad you mentioned trust it's
it's a very long process and you know we
just want to make sure that that others
don't do that and that was a wonderful
story about very sad about the
Portuguese um various well so I guess
you probably have some expertise I want
to say or some experience in these
situations and again I think the other
main lesson I'm getting from you is uh
you know in these difficult situations
it's always good to have somebody who
has experience in these situations I
think if we just go in as you know just
researchers or filmmakers who don't know
anything about the situation never
worked in similar situations we are
likely to cause more harm than to do
good so I think it's it's worth it for
us to to actually think about that but
um uh you know I I echocc who said that
I learned so much from sohil and the
rohingya people I did too just watching
this documentary for an hour and 15
minutes I think I learned more than
reading everything and you know really
he it really sank you know sank in in a
way that I can read any news article or
whatever Proclamation but this really
brings it home and and also to thank you
for the chance let us witness the
stories I'm I'm going to actually just
call on Teresa Delgado who's the head of
the the refugee uh program at McMillan
um to say a few words because I think
this is thanks to it was organized
through the the program the refugee
program McMillan and this is one of the
many things that the the center does so
Teresa if I can have you just say a few
words and then I'll I'll close this
and thank you so much to I hope I've
answered if I haven't answered any or
Sohail hasn't answered any audience
questions I haven't had a chance to ask
him can you re just copy it so that I
know that we haven't answered it but I
think we have gone through all and thank
you for being such an Engaged audience
um Theresa
yeah
um no I just want as well to thank
um everybody for participating in in
this session and for us we see the role
that we have as mainly sort of uh
given the opportunity to people to
see and share the experiences of others
um of the refugee of people who have no
voice so actually we see this as a
platform and given that we are here at
Yale I think our role is just to
um
I mean engage in with programs as well
as like the white rice in terms of the
research that can be done but balancing
also with the other type of uh
dissemination let's say of showing I
mean all of the what so hell was talking
about the empathy uh I guess in order to
to relate to the refugees and and give
them their
yeah the the rights that have been taken
aback so I hope you can continue to
um
um
participate and to watch the seminars
and films and and if you have any
suggestions please do write to to us
thank you
okay thank you thank you Teresa I think
the the program on refugees uh does a
huge job in terms of making these
stories accessible and I agree with you
I think that
um the the stories that Sohail and other
filmmakers and storytellers talk about
is just as valuable when we say data as
the kind of you know hard data or
quantitative data that we might do as an
academic research center I think if you
want to move people you've got to show
them not just the numbers but also the
the stories of people's lives so I think
this is a fantastic fantastic end to
those on today who are present today I
think there's a link to see the film
we'd request that you not share it
widely right now uh because I think it's
still being shown
um but yes we hope that you know you do
have a chance to catch up with this
fantastic film so thank you to everyone
um you know to the Yale MacMillan Center
program and refugees are bringing this
before so hail of course for the courage
and the patience and you know it
requires and the resilience and most of
all of course uh if you ever get a
chance to speak uh you know with with
the children and with others in the camp
to tell them like how moved we were by
the stories and uh to wish them well
actually